foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people
build wealth do work
that they actually love and create
actual real amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsey personality star of the
new YouTube Sensations Channel called
oddly enough the George Campbell Channel
creative yes very creative and uh
co-host of the exploding uh popular
podcast and YouTube show smart money
happy hour with our own Rachel Cruz is
my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Jane starts
this hour in Chicago hi Jane how are you
it's Friday where are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
so I'm trying to
trying to buy someone whether and I I
should buy another used car or buy a new
car I have a 2012 Hyundai Sonata now
I've already paid four thousand dollars
in repairs and the car is still not
fixed it's overheating I've been kind of
getting to run around with mechanics and
I just don't want to keep spending money
into the car I got it from my auction so
it's a salvage title there's that I
don't know if it makes a difference
um I have about ninety thousand dollars
between a CD which doesn't mature until
April of next year I have arrived in
probably about 60
000 this liquid
um so I was just gonna buy like a Toyota
Camry for 30 000 but I didn't know if it
was smart to buy a cash car I mean buy a
car cash or what to do that is the only
smart thing to do when it comes to cars
so do you do you have any debt
whatsoever
no I have no well I have a mortgage okay
and then what's your income
uh after taxes forty thousand
I would not buy a 30 000 car if I made
40. that's just too much of your world
tied up in that depreciating asset is
there something in between we could get
like a fifteen thousand dollar car and
we sell off the Santa Fe for what we can
get for it
yeah I could I just I didn't I was alive
yeah I wanted hey Jane yes
you're pissed off and sick of your car
breaking down and that frustration is
getting ready to cause you to overdo
this decision
okay I don't blame you nothing makes you
more mad than sitting on the side of Dad
Gum Road or taking something back to get
it fixed four times it's still not fixed
that's enough to make you do something
stupid and you're about to if you're not
careful
just because you're mad I don't blame
you for being frustrated what you're
going through is frustrating but you
don't go from a two thousand dollar car
to a thirty thousand dollar car in one
Fell Swoop when you make 40 Grand that's
that's in that's in the column a dome
girl you don't want to do that
just because you're mad I don't I mean I
get it okay you want something that when
I turn the key it by God starts don't
you
yes and you can get that for less than
30 honey so here here's the here's the
overall
thing you got to think of when you're
making decisions like this what do
people who have millions of dollars who
started with nothing
what did they do in situations like this
and we've actually studied them over ten
thousand millionaires that we studied
and they did not buy brand new vehicles
before they had at least a million
dollars in net worth uh because brand
new vehicles go down in value like
George just pointed out to you you're in
too much of your life point because that
30 is going to turn into 15 in about 20
seconds you know that right
cars go down in value Like a Rock that's
why Chevy has that commercial like a
rock
you know what I'm saying
so you can get you a really nice used
car in the smart column
for ten or fifteen thousand dollars
that'll do that is going to be a
bazillion times better and that piece of
crap you've been dealing with and I
don't blame you for getting rid of it
and you've got the money to pay cash for
it and of course you pay cash for it car
payments are what middle class people do
and it's not a bad thing but if you want
to be middle class keep a car payment it
pretty much guarantees you're always
going to be middle class
from a wealth building perspective
because you just always got a car
payment and uh yeah it's the middle
class thing of stupid
and rich people do some stupid things
middle class people do stupid stuff poor
people do stupid stuff but it's
different stupid stuff
and the middle class one is the car
payment that's the one mathematically
that takes you down so please pay cash
and please buy you a nice used car
for under twenty thousand dollars
preferably like George suggested around
with a clean title this time yeah no
salary and get it inspected get a
pre-purchase inspection it'll cost you
100 bucks and it'll give you peace of
mind yeah you want to get you want to
get something where you do turn the key
and it turns on but you can get a
wonderful vehicle right now for fifteen
thousand dollars that will drive you for
the next decade a wonderful vehicle and
there's lots of you know the thing is
the way they build cars now they last if
you take care of them now not
necessarily if they've been in a flood
or whatever the Salvage situation was
that caused this thing to have an
overheating problem that they can't
figure out and its electronic brain is
probably fried or whatever it is but
yeah no Salvage time don't look for a uh
the wrong kind of bargain look for
something that is Dependable Dependable
Dependable low miles and that that you
know it just it just screams it's gonna
and let me see you set a Toyota Camry
hey a 15 000 Camry right now that's a
great car it might be 10 years old and
it'll last another 10 or 20. yeah I mean
you can get a lot of American-made stuff
a lot of a lot of foreign made stuff
that that is and for that matter half
the foreign made stuff is now made in
America weird mix yeah Toyota truck
plant is all made here you know so there
you go Nissan made right here outside of
Nashville so uh you know you just
uh who makes what anymore but anyway the
the point being
not waving a flag but the point is just
get something that works and that is
consistent and
um George it's important to point out to
everybody that that it's not just uh
Jane we all have this thing of we do two
things in our culture we we say three
things I'll throw in a third one while
I'm thinking of off the top of my head
here
the safety reliability and Status cause
us to buy way more vehicle than you can
afford
and your car is safe and it is reliable
and no it doesn't have any status so
shut up but so what if you attract
people into your life because of what
you drive you did not attract quality
humans and when you have a kid you don't
need to go buy a Tahoe for the kid that
often happens like oh Dave we got kids
now we got to get the most gigantic
expensive SUV for the kids you're gonna
give the 16 year old time well a guy
called the other day he had a hoopty car
engine transmission issues and he went
and financed the sixty thousand dollar
car yeah because of his car made that
same that's another hint okay unless you
suddenly inherited two million dollars
you don't need to make a jump 10x in
your car
so if your car is worth three grand and
you jump into 30 hint you're probably
screwing up
in Jane's point I made that point to her
too okay I've done all this stuff that's
all I know I did I've done stupid with
zeros on the end I have a PhD in dumb
people that's how I know it so we're
here with you we're walking with you
we're just a little further down the
road than some of you that's why we do
this show good pun this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
honored to have uh entree Leadership
Summit full of great thought leaders
next week great people talking about
leadership and talking about business
I'm really excited to be with about 3
000 folks one of the folks I'm excited
to be with is one of our speakers Dr
Jordan Peterson uh author of the huge
best seller 12 rules of life and uh
personal Terrorizer of all things
Twitter
I enjoyed getting to looking forward to
getting to spend some time with him and
we wanted to have him on today to talk
just a little bit welcome Dr Peterson
how are you thank you good good how are
you doing doing great man we're excited
to have you next week thanks for coming
okay my pleasure I'm looking forward to
it you've been uh you've been on the
road you're up it looks like all over
the place huh
yeah for a long time I don't know we've
been 400 cities my wife and I something
like that in the last couple of years
yeah it's been been a brutal run it
looks like so Nashville will be one of
the stops on Stateside as we said next
week so with these leadership guys
talking next week what is what is the
plan for your keynote what are you going
to be talking about
probably about vision and I thought
that's something we could discuss today
in in Principle as well
yes I I completely agree with that I've
looked at a lot of the stuff and a lot
of your comments not only on uh
wealth inequality issues but also just
on the person the psychology of handling
money one of the things we say around
Ramsey all the time is personal finance
is 80 Behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge and getting the guy in the
mirror to behave is is the battle and
and you've you've got a lot to say uh on
that subject so talk about what you've
discovered around the correlation
between just a mental uh stability a
mental maturity mental health maturity
and and that how that correlates to
wealth
well people it's easy to presume that
the reason people are poor is because
they don't have enough money
but that's an oversimplification very
few complex things are attributable to a
single cause
um I had lots of clients who were much
better off when they had no money at all
those are often people who had addiction
problems because as soon as they had any
money at all they're just in the bar and
into the cocaine until they were face
down in a ditch and
so there's there's all sorts of causes
of poverty and certainly one form of
poverty and one cause of poverty is
absence of a plan
I mean you need to develop a vision for
your life and that makes delaying
gratification for example and not
engaging in impulsive momentary pleasure
worthwhile because you're building
towards something that you actually want
to attain and we're very very bad at in
our society like appallingly and
miraculously bad at helping people
develop a vision we don't do it with
students in school for example not at
all and it's it's really like I said
it's a miracle of stupidity
so
it is it truly is it's the it's the
number one thing we should be teaching
people and we don't do it at all who do
you want to be and why what do you want
your life to look like in five years
what are you building towards why are
you
in gratification assume you are why are
you saving for example or working like
what what's your vision what makes it
worthwhile and how do you even come up
with an ocean like that
the strange thing is when you have a
vision that's very very clear in high
definition uh burnout just kind of goes
away you get tired like your schedule
has been horrendous but you're not burnt
out you're probably tired but you're not
burnt out
yeah well I mean look
all the positive emotion we feel
that uh except for the type that is just
a consequence of basic satisfaction you
know the sort of satisfaction you might
have after a big meal all the enthusiasm
and excitement and hope and curiosity
essential meaning in life all of that
all of that is experienced in
relationship to a goal when you see
yourself moving towards a goal
then you're inspired you have you have
hope you have enthusiasm you have energy
um you can communicate effectively and
enthusiastically no goal you have none
of that no vision no goal
so
you're not going to get tired and and
feel what would you say hard done by if
your sacrifices and the difficult things
that you're endeavoring to do are
clearly worthwhile by your own
definition
and one of the things I do I have an
exercise online called it's at
self-authoring.com called future
authoring and we built this to help
people develop a vision and one of the
things we ask people to do is just to
sit for 15 minutes right for 15 minutes
badly
here's the game imagine you were taking
care of yourself like someone you cared
for so imagine someone you care for and
pretend that's you maybe it's a son or a
daughter or a friend
now imagine five years down the road
you can have what you want need you can
be who you are but you have to figure
out what it is what is it what do you
want what do you need
and and don't worry about getting it
right just get it down for 15 minutes
that's a good start the whole exercise
you can do in about 90 minutes but we
had
students do that say before they went to
University
and just doing it for 90 minutes
developing that Vision drop their
dropout rate 90 or 50 percent 50 percent
and increase the grade point average 35
percent
and that just shows you how badly it had
been done before because
students went to University with no
vision they have no idea what they were
doing there and so of course they didn't
half of them didn't succeed because they
had no idea why they were doing anything
well that's not helpful or wise and the
reason that's the case by the way is
because our school system was set up to
produce
mindless obedient workers by essentially
by fascists at the end of the 1800s
that's well documented historically it
was based on the Prussian military model
and they wanted to produce obedient
soldiers and we haven't updated our
notion of what schools are for for 140
years yeah Ken Coleman says we've not
made Pathfinders we've made test takers
if that we're not even very good at that
well Dr Peterson I'm curious Pathfinders
we have so many similar principles we
want to help people avoid the pitfalls
of education and debt and we're both
kind of Truth tellers in a world gone
mad and that can be counter-cultural
controversial offensive at times what is
the secret sauce to really connecting
with those people and getting to change
a paradigm and actually getting out of
debt or doing that hard thing
well I think a huge part of that is to
get them to start conceptualizing
themselves as people who could be
pursuing
um a goal that they found compelling
rather than people who are driven by
circumstances I think it's 35 40 percent
of Young Americans now feel they have no
agency in their life
and you say well how do you you have to
entice people into I suppose the
hypothesis of a vision and you do that
well well this
this meditative exercise for example
that I described just imagine for a
moment that you could have what you
needed and wanted
mine and I mean literally imagine that
Daydream like you did when you were a
kid
now you know you want to bind that with
a little bit of intelligent rationality
you you know you you don't want to be
if you're starting it from scratch maybe
you don't want to be thinking that in
five years you're gonna inhabit a 350
room Mansion you know in in Malibu
although stranger things have happened
to people you know you want to
you want to develop your vision within
the realm of possibility but that
doesn't but and you and you should be
honest enough with yourself so it's
actually something compelling to you you
know the other thing we ask people to do
and I'm talking about this because it's
very practical you might say well I
don't know what I want it's like okay
well what other people have that it
seems to work for them you probably want
a relationship what's your vision for
that you probably want to have something
approximating a family of some sort
what's your vision for that even if it's
your parents not children necessary not
even a wife necessarily some family
connections some friendship some job or
career some educational goals some
strategy for dealing with Temptations
that's five things some conception of
how you would use your time
intelligently outside of work
um some conception of how you might what
would you say uphold your civic
responsibility yeah there's there's
sources of meaning that people that
people generally have Dr Peterson we are
so looking forward to seeing you next
week
thanks for taking time out of your crazy
schedule and spending a minute with us
look forward to continuing this
discussion a bunch thanks for coming on
with us yeah yeah thanks for the
invitation this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today
he's trying to give Dr Peterson as much
room as I could in that segment because
he always has a lot of pretty
interesting things to say always keeps
you on your toes for sure and but I blew
it in the process of doing that because
I'm supposed to remind you guys out
there that entree Leadership Summit is
next week and it is sold out so if you
don't have a ticket you're not coming
um sorry about the fomo but it's 3 200
folks and it's Malcolm Gladwell
Willie Robertson Dr Jordan Peterson me
Ken Coleman Dr John deloney many others
Brian buffini several other people
speaking and teaching on leadership uh
for three or four days in a row there at
the great Opryland hotel resort and uh
the bad news is you're not coming if you
don't have a ticket the good news is you
can actually watch it if you want to see
one of the Premier leadership events in
the world right now including Dr
Peterson's presentation you can actually
watch it on a live stream and you can
purchase that and you can do that from
us
ramseysolutions.com just click on entree
Leadership Summit and it will take you
to the live stream and there we'll go
from there so George uh car payments
we talked about this earlier equal
retirement they're costing people a
whole lot of wealth and all your life
people have heard it's normal to have a
car payment but hear me out the average
car payment in America right now is
around 600 bucks a month uh higher in
some studies and if you invested that
instead each month into your 401k a Roth
IRA you could retire with get this more
than 7.1 million dollars after 40 Years
of not having a car payment for age 25
to age 65 7 million bucks so George if
you're half wrong they'd still be okay
that's still a good life and you're
still debt free with no car payment and
that's why most millionaires they pay
cash for used reliable cars and never
lease or buy new you see Building Wealth
is not some secret you can learn the
same plan that Millions have used to pay
off their debt build wealth and invest
and it's all in Dave Ramsey's
best-selling books The Total Money
Makeover and his newest baby steps
Millionaires and even better news you
can get them today for just 10 bucks
each in our ten dollar sale that's
pretty wild
pretty cool all that ramsesolutions.com
yeah miss it out and a lot of the a lot
almost all of our books delony's
Rachel's comments that are number one
best sellers all they're on sale for ten
dollars right now so check them out
we've risen above inflation Somehow Here
Dave yeah that sale doesn't last um well
not for long because I I did declare in
a meeting the other day the 11 sale next
year guys no it's gonna be more than
that because our cost our paper cost has
gone through the roof and uh man it's
costing us almost double what it used to
cost us to build a book now wow so I'll
get it while you can then yeah welcome
to uh welcome to businesses passing
along inflation to you
except for the Costco hot dog somehow
they're still trucking along yeah I
think that that's just a National
Treasure all right let's go to uh Andrew
in San Jose hey Andrew welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey what's up so
um we've been working through baby step
two for about four months and doing
December so far I thought me and my wife
are debating about having a birthday
party for our two kids as her sister who
doesn't come down very often is going to
be over about two months or signs up
with that
um should I argue with her about it or
did I should should I just shut up and
put it in the budget
I'm sorry
you're arguing about a birthday party
for your children whether you can afford
that
yes what are you spending
on a birthday party for children
not ton but I'm just in what's a term is
that 50 bucks or 500 bucks a couple
hundred bucks probably like probably up
to four to five probably around the
range and these children are held
okay all right
uh well so the one-year-old birthday
party is really for the adults
I know that's why I'm asking
um and so I I you know
are people invited to this a big party
or inviting a lot of people or is this
more just for the family family okay
does your wife cook
Ed I wonder if she could like make a
cake
like my mom did for my birthday I never
had a store-bought cake until I was in
college
I didn't know you could get a cake at
the store I didn't know that was an
option
and I and I haven't said that one time
to a therapist I've made it okay
so I mean you know good old Duncan Hines
right
um so I mean I think you could have a
whale of a party for 100 bucks if you
kind of put your heads together yes I
think you ought to have a birthday party
for your children but do we have to have
um six dancing ponies that cost two
thousand dollars no we'll have to skip
the petting zoo and the Inflatables this
year
something more reasonable is the way
they could do it no I go to the dollar
store and get some cheap decorum plates
it'll cost you five bucks hey and let me
tell you what happens with Sharon and me
too is we start arguing about Concepts
and we've actually end up with actual
similar numbers in our heads like she's
got this big party in her mind for
instance maybe you've got a small party
in your mind and if you actually sat
down and wrote out what you're going to
spend both of you would probably
wouldn't be that far apart
how could we do how could we do the part
you know a good question would be I
think a party is very important this is
you talking to your wife I think a party
is very important it's really important
for a one-year-old that we celebrate
that we don't we only get one of those
we don't want to miss out on that okay
and uh so let's have a big party how can
we do that given that we have this goal
of of trying to remain reasonable with
our budgeting and so what are you
thinking of spending
and how can we you know how can we do
how can we get a lot of bang for our
buck and I'll help
you know
um I'll get out the directions and bake
a cake if you could do that it wouldn't
kill you and um I could probably pull it
off and I'm really stuck in the kitchen
but I could probably pull off a cake
might take a couple tries but still be
cheaper than buying one Dave just
auditioned for the Great British Bake
Off this happened there there's a thing
called the British Bakery it's big on
Netflix the kids watch it okay but
Andrew the key here is you don't want to
set you back on your debt free Journey
you might be closer than you think you
are when you have a discussion
that's not about do a party or not do a
party it's more about what do we spend
on a party that is reasonable
and when Sharon and I start doing that
she's kind of talking in these flowery
terms about buying you know redecorating
the home and I'm like okay crap I just
heard two hundred thousand dollars and
she's thinking two thousand dollars I
just wanted another thing in there you
know and I'm like oh I should have shut
up and listened okay because I I she
said redecorate I heard 200 she was
saying you know to 2003 you know what
I'm saying yes sometimes you miss each
other because all I hear is one thing in
my head goes from warning warning
warning yeah you take into the details
you heard party and you went my budget
is busted I'm trashed Dave Ramsey is
going to come to my house and hit me
with a baseball bat no none of that's
true okay it's not going to happen well
you can go to Costco and get two pizzas
and a sheet cake for like 30 bucks and
call it a day see now there you went
buying cakes again you can get a sheet
cake at Costco oh yeah 30 bucks yeah
they put your face on it whatever you
want to do they'll do it how is it that
you know this George I've been known to
shop your Costco put your face you can
do anything
a charge cake Dave I'm sure people have
sent you cake with your face has that
not happened yet we didn't eat those no
that's that's not edible there's
something weird about cutting into your
own face it's just this it's
uncomfortable that's just yeah I worry
about what's in that cake but how do you
Dave how do you grapple with folks that
are in baby step two and things come up
we had one about a quinceanera and she
was going to spend eight thousand
dollars because she needed to go on the
cruise for her niece for the quinceanera
and we said no you're not going on the
cruise nope so what is that what are the
boundary conversations you need to have
what are the financial pieces that you
need to go I mean what if
you had to do something you really
couldn't afford
what would you say
okay in order to make the 16 year old
niece happy you need to buy her a 600
000 Bentley
you would go well that's stupid of
course I'm not doing that hey I don't
have six hundred thousand dollars B I
don't have a Bentley so she's sure not
getting one so see I hadn't been on a
cruise so I'm sure not going on one for
you
you know and I don't have eight thousand
dollars because I'm broke people in debt
but you gotta you gotta extrapolate this
stuff in your mind to go with the
absurdity of the request if you if you
just pan back and go what if it was at a
zero to it you would go well no well
that's the way we're looking at it when
you bring up something like spending
eight thousand dollars on a child's
child's Cruise while you're broke now we
know why you're broke this is the Ramsay
show
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thanks for joining us if
you want to understand a little bit more
about what's going on with all things
Ramsey we got a little free process to
help you just go to ramsesolutions.com
click the get started button it'll help
you ascertain where you are and what the
next steps are to get where you want to
be yeah that's how that works so get
started at ramseysolutions.com of course
completely free George Campbell Ramsey
personality my co-host today and Madison
Portland Oregon hey Matt welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um I recently discovered your show and
really can't get enough so thank you
thank you I'm 52. yeah I'm 52 my wife is
47 and our household take-home is
roughly 8 000 a month
we have a thirty four thousand dollars
in an IRA
instead of traditional investing we've
gone the real estate route and currently
have mortgages on three homes one is a
primary residence and tour rentals
um and
just needs some advice I I up until I
discovered you guys
um this was our pretty solid plan but uh
um is it too late to to go the
traditional investing route or no
and it's not necessary that you only do
the traditional investing route
um I've got a bunch of real estate as a
matter of fact I have more real estate
than I have mutual funds
because I love real estate like you do
um and so you know as long as we're
Building Wealth somewhere we're
certainly not going to be out of there
what I would want to do is I would want
to lean in and have a plan to knock
those mortgages out sooner rather than
later without panicking about it
so what are the balances on these
puppies
let's see primary residence 315
rental number one is 200 000 and then
rental number two is 225. okay all right
we do we you know we we can pay them off
in 15 years
um yeah you probably pay them off a lot
faster than that
probably I'm often about eight if you
lean into it a little bit and um so I
would start I mean you throw your rents
back at it number one you ought to be
getting substantial rents on these
things what are the what's the 200 000
mortgage rental worth
about 300 right now okay you're not
making much on that one what's the uh
225 rental worth
that's worth about 350. we added a
bathroom and and did some stuff on that
yeah you're you're not you're not cash
flowing a ton on either one of these
you're making money but you're not like
bailing it or anything no
no these were recent acquisitions and uh
you know our plan
is to you know have them paid off in 15
years yeah and you can work that but I
would work towards paying them off
faster I certainly wouldn't add any more
to this because you you don't have
enough equity in these things for them
to be making a ton of money they're
you know the the this will work out for
you but it's it's not going to for a
while
it's gonna be you're gonna be you know
spinning your wheels for a little while
because you just don't have any margin
in these things there's not enough
equity for you to have big cash flow and
if you don't have big cash flow you're
not making big money
translation right every dollar you've
put into this is not getting an Roi yet
except in increased value but you're not
getting cash on cash rois not to amount
anything
do you guys have any other debt
uh we do have a car loan at 15 000 but
other than that no credit card debt
what's your casualties you said
we we have we have about 12 000 in the
bank right now
okay well first thing is you got to get
your emergency fund up because you're
sitting on a lot of debt and a lot of
potential problems with no cash
you get two or three heat and errors go
out or two heat and airs go out and the
water heater blow between these three
properties and a short period of span
you got a problem you're going to be
looking at debt
yeah yeah do you love both rentals or is
there one of them that gives you a
headache that you wouldn't mind selling
you just got them
I mean we've had them for a couple years
or a year and a half
um we do we love them
yeah but one of them we really love
we're going to move into at some point
but uh
the other one is just a rental yeah well
point being if you're gonna if you want
to hold these if you want to clear them
that's fine get rid of them it's not
you're not going to lose much uh uh if
you want to play through on your plan
what you do need to do is continue to
follow the baby steps get your emergency
fund up uh you need a pretty substantial
cash position to be holding this kind of
property probably 75 grand and you're
sitting on 12. and uh because you just
got a lot of exposure that's going to
have cash needs and the problem is these
things all come in threes believe me
I've been managing property for 40 years
and so it's just it's it's always the
perfect freaking storm basement leak
stupid car runs through the fence I mean
it's something you just when you own
property it goes with the territory I
love real estate but it is a hassle
compared to on a mutual fund so number
one get your emergency fund up then
number two I would start with a
two-pronged approach of getting these
paid down pretty aggressively and also
let's reach over and uh uh start that 15
going into retirement and get rid of
this card debt card that's got to go
forward to anything that's you're going
to get rid of that tomorrow that that's
just ridiculous yeah not the car but the
car debt so first work your baby steps
man you just started listening baby step
one's a thousand dollars safe you've
done that two is debt free but the house
need to knock out the car like George
said three is three to six months
offenses say for emergencies in your
case I'm going to jack that on up to 75
because you got heavy expenses with
these rentals that you don't have a cash
position to cover then four is we start
putting 15 of our income into retirement
you work all of that for the next uh 15
years you're going to have a bunch of
paid for property and you're going to
have a pile of cash over mutual funds
also and you're going to be in really
good shape but you're gonna have to lean
into it and be very intentional
sometimes when people first start buying
property and you're a little bit further
into this you're not brand new but we
feel like
uh like it's magic and it's
automatically works and it's anything
but magic and anything but automatic
well everyone says it's passive income
Dave pass passive about anybody says
real estate's passive incomes never
manage real estate there's nothing
passive about it it's freaking active as
it can be that's an absurd but statement
when people say that that's somebody
selling a get rich quick thing on Tic
Tac you know that's all that is it's
just not even real all right Amanda is
in Cincinnati hey Amanda welcome to the
Ramsey Show
sure what's up
um so I
I've been trying to implement what I've
been hearing so my husband and I had a
Whole Life policies so we got rid of
those with banner Scott Sherman policies
and we have three children
um six and under so we did the writer
for the children good but um we have
the whole life policy we were talking to
getting for my older son when he was an
infant he was 15 years pay and we are
six years in so should we get rid of
that also sure
okay he absolutely sucks yeah the money
you put into it you're going to get very
little out of it has a horrible rate of
return it is not good for saving money
and it's not good for insurance you got
him covered for insurance now with a
rider right
correct yeah so now it's just the
question is is our whole life policy a
good investment to which everyone in the
financial planning world that doesn't
sell that crap is laughing of course
it's not a good investment it's a
horrible investment much better off to
take any money you get out of that
policy and any money you are putting
into it monthly and put that in a good
mutual fund in a 529 for his college I
thought Dave had a Whole Life policies
were going to start to die off but it's
only gotten louder with social media and
index universal life and infinite
Banking and all these Concepts now that
are being talented those aren't new
though those are 40 year old ideas
they're making them fancy and Slick now
with one minute videos put them on Tic
Tac with somebody with good hair and all
of a sudden everybody's talking about it
but you know it's just it's the same old
crap
you know it's just it's a yeah yes
Amanda to answer your question honey get
rid of your Whole Life policies you've
got the child covered you don't even
really need child coverage except enough
to bury them if God forbid something
happens because they're not creating an
income that the household is dependent
upon you however are creating an income
that the household is dependent upon you
need to replace that income with a big
term life policy 10 to 12 times your
income so you make fifty thousand you
need five to six hundred thousand on you
to cut to invest that would then create
fifty thousand and replace the income
that is lost with the death of an income
producing adult children do not need
life insurance except enough for quote
final expenses we call it do not have to
say and insurance is not an investment
don't believe anyone who says it never
never listen you don't get your muffler
fixed at the transmission store
don't go to life insurance people to do
investing
you know I you seriously no thank you
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to ramsesolutions.com
today to sign up for the newsletter
again that's ramsesolutions.com to sign
up for our Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Georgia Campbell Ramsay
personality co-host of the smart money
happy hour with Rachel Cruz is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Lisa is in Indianapolis hi Lisa welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi oh my goodness
I'm really nervous that's okay we've
never lost a patient what's up okay okay
good
um so um just to get to the point here
about 15 years ago my husband took out a
HELOC how many years ago an opportunity
about 15 15 years ago
he took out a HELOC okay uh-huh for an
investment opportunity
and the last few years it hasn't been
paying dividends
it's with his company
and we started Jade's Class A few weeks
ago and I love her she's awesome and
we're we're going through the baby steps
and I just feel like we're so out of
order because we had our house paid off
um and then
and then he I'm sorry
um did this investment opportunity and
now I feel like
um
I'm I'm a little bitter and I'm having a
hard time being on board to pay this off
together because I'm just upset about it
because where were you 15 years ago
I had two babies and I said I don't
agree with it
and you signed the papers anyway
no I didn't sign any papers yes you did
you don't get a HELOC on someone's
personal residence without spouse's
signature
I didn't sign in
I didn't know that
okay
and um
well I it doesn't matter now there's a
HELOC on your house okay uh but
um I yeah it might matter I don't know
um
okay so what do you want to do
I don't know I was motivated to get
um how much is the debt
that's up to 283
000. what does your husband make the
name debt we have
about
what was his investment into his company
he bought into a a partnership or what
um
company
private firm he made all this money off
the shares where did that money go he
um he reinvested 500 000 first he paid
off our house which is great
and then the rest of it about 500 000 he
reinvested in the company
and then I guess he was so excited he
decided oh well you know we're getting a
dividend of six absolutely the
investment into the new company is in
what form
this is a publicly traded company or
what no it's not it's just um
it's just the country
he still works there a private it's
uh-huh
[Music]
so what percentage of this company does
he own
I don't uh he I don't even know he has
he has 70 about 75 000 shares and I
asked them what are the rules to get out
of it
can you sell them
two and he's like oh no we can sell them
and they said well
let's talk to her let's talk to
whoever's in charge of this and see what
we can do yeah
to sell it yeah
so that's kind of on his assignment
because you know when we started this
class A few weeks ago it's not going to
do with the class it's got to do it's
got to just do with common sense
we need to clear up this mess you've
made and you're playing Russian roulette
with our house
it ain't cool dude
it's not have you shared with him your
feelings about this strongly saying I
don't feel safe I want this deck gone
is he actually listening to that or is
he going well just trust me trust me I
got this
when I bring it up
kill either leave the room or last week
I just started crying and talking about
it
and I don't and the thing is he's like
the nicest person in the world he's not
like a jerk who doesn't go out and buy
things for himself or anything oh I I
beg to differ
yeah I think he bought a lot of stuff
for himself like five hundred thousand
dollars worth
while putting your home at risk
yeah so yeah we need to liquidate this
it's not hey it's not paying dividends
it's not working uh so I'm kind of I'm
kind of worried about the quality of the
company at this stage of the game
um and whether you're ever going to get
a half a million dollars out of it or
not and B uh you want to get your house
paid off and uh that you know he
basically borrowed on your home to
invest in a business that he's a
minority shareholder in
which is just dangerous
can be
that's just dangerous because he got no
phone he can't you know I if you don't
have if you're not a majority
shareholder meaning 51 you don't control
the outcomes of the company
and so other people vote your prosperity
in or out
right and that's what's happening here I
can I can tell by the way you've
structured this
conversation so yeah he needs to uh that
this sweet man needs to get his money
out of his company and pay off his home
and
um and never sign his wife's name again
without her without having a power of
attorney
um because I don't unless unless Indiana
has different laws than most States uh
you don't get a home equity loan without
both spousals suppose spouse is signing
on a property
on your personal residence now you could
do it on a investment property in some
states but you can't do it on your
personal residence Title Company won't
cover it so now Dave I've heard you talk
about agreeing with your spouse on
financial decisions and you and Sharon
do this so if you say hey I want to
invest this money over here and Sharon
has a strong feeling as you say yeah is
it just not happening what's the
conversation we argue about it until I'm
right but I don't know I'll argue about
it until she's right but you know we
come to a conclusion but we're not when
in doubt don't
is the rule and and so uh and you know
these days Lisa what you're what your
role is is the same as Sharon's because
this is the type of crap I did in the
old days I'm not signing her name but uh
uh I'm not 100 sure he did that but I'm
kind of thinking he did
um but the uh uh but but this idea of
I'm gonna do this this is the right
thing and she's got two kids and she's
like whatever you want to do go ahead
and she would say like whatever you want
to do honey which is Southern for you
wreck it by yourself Bubba and then I'm
gonna make fun of you that's what that
means and so uh you know no we need to
have a meeting of the minds we need to
be and Lisa Your Role from this point
forward is speak up loudly do you have a
voice you have a vote and both of you
get a vote and if both of you don't
place your votes you stand a much higher
probability of losing money on things
and buying the wrong things at the wrong
times this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
rather
one guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today our
question of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services to
repair maintain or improve your home
researching dozens of providers is a
thing of the past neighborly is all you
need to remember for a nationwide
network of local home service pros great
company by the way visit neighborly.com
to find help near you today's question
comes from Ben in Florida he writes I
understand tipping 20 at a restaurant
when I'm dining in but am I obligated to
tip at a restaurant when I place a to-go
order there's no service provided other
than making a meal and I drove to pick
it up am I wrong here I'm curious what
your thoughts are with how crazy tipping
has become culturally
this has been all over Dave as self
checkouts now have tipping screens so
everyone's really funny bits on this we
had their social media stuff on George
Campbell look him up on social media
making fun of the uh the typical spin
tip move where they spin the thing
around at the fast food joint and ask
you to tip well and it's always the uh
it's just gonna ask you a question like
you don't know what the question is yeah
you know it's always the other one
scenario the other one I saw the other
day I was cracking up and you we teach
generosity let's just be clear okay one
of the reasons to get your money
together is to be crazy generous but the
other one was it's like I go into this
guy said I go into a grocery store and
they're like do you want to add ten
dollars for Hungry children he's like no
I want this Mega Corporation to pay for
Hungry children I'm not adding ten
dollars it's like oh everywhere you go
I'm checking out buying a dog collar do
you want to help dogs oh yeah they have
it on online I mean PetSmart's got a
thing right everywhere they got a done
for ten dollars for starving something
and uh listen I I totally believe in
taking care of pets I totally believe in
taking care of uh Starving Children and
all that but I don't do it at the uh
when I'm checking out I'm more
thoughtful with my generosity and much
larger with my generosity than that now
having said all that the the spin move
is this is kind of Middle Ground here on
the to-go order
I think dining in I'm outrageously
tipping valets I'm outrageously tipping
a they're out in the rain the sun b
they're driving my really nice car and I
don't want Ferris Bueller's Day out I'm
outrageously tipping okay so uh all
right so now we've covered that stuff I
believe in tipping I always leave a a
really nice large bill as a tent on the
uh bed when I leave a hotel room that's
sitting right there on the end so it's
obvious what it was for the uh the
person that's nice enough to clean up
that room for me and I didn't have to
make my bed that day life is pretty good
so uh you know I tip I believe in
tipping there were some physical
Services provided tipping at a fast food
joint no tipping at the Starbucks line
no
tipping your driver sure
tipping your Bellman you're better yeah
this guy yeah big time be outrageously
generous with tipping this one is kind
of in the middle it's not really fast
food
it's a dine-in nice restaurant or a
semi-nice restaurant that would have
given you the opportunity to tip were
you to have sat down and had a waiter
which you did not have but sometimes
they assign a waiter a host or a person
to work this table yes and that's the
the caveat here is there is physical
effort involved with packaging up all
your stuff making sure the order is
right adding the utens all of that but
it's not the same level of service as I
walk up today 17 times to make sure he's
got water make sure he's got what he
needs you know showed him the menu
recommended some wine whatever it is so
I don't see it in the same category I
don't tip 20 on to-go orders unless it
was a giant group order catering they
out served me they were amazing but
generally it's a buck or two maybe ten
percent on a to-go order and some people
actually force it now there's one
restaurant in town that I get to go
orders from they have a 10 service fee
built in to go orders so businesses are
just going we're going to force a
gratuity which I'm not a fan of
but they can do what they want to do
they didn't force you to shop there no I
chose to still eat that all right so
yeah that's the caveat uh but I don't
like the guilted generosity or the
fourth generation that's the thing with
the starving children in the grocery
store thing yeah
uh so should you um I think it's a nice
thing to do and I think it's a great
reason to get your finances in order to
just to be able to do that but if you
feel guilted into it I wouldn't do it
out of guilt
I'm gonna make eye contact while I spin
the screen around and go custom tip 0.00
there we go that's the way
Savage but I got hate on this Dave
because we posted and all the comments
and they're saying I work in the service
industry and I can't believe you don't
tip 25 work in the service industry if
you work in fast food
let me help you with this you work in a
fast food place that's not the service
industry
the service industry is where you
provide service not where you hand food
over the counter that someone else
cooked no that I'm sorry you're a
cashier if you work in the fast food
where does the line end Dave our grocery
stores are we going to start tipping I
mean they bag our groceries back should
we not if the guy takes under my car
those guys yeah absolutely we're getting
a tip absolutely but just for scanning
it through the checkout line I don't
think it qualifies as gratuity no
and uh I was in uh Mexico and went to a
nice uh they have a whole different cusp
set of Customs right a nice grocery
store a high-end grocery store so to
speak if you can get that right in your
head but um it's the whole thing this is
not a this is not this you know this is
a nice place and they don't they don't
do bags you bring your own bag right and
if you don't have your own bag there's
these nice little
uh 90 year old Mexican ladies standing
at the end of the thing boxing the stuff
up in boxes that they brought from the
back and helping you out and I always
over tip those ladies there's just
something about them that just says big
money big money so yeah I want to do
that for sure this one I'm kind of going
to be 50 50. I got two thoughts on it
one is that I won't be guilted into
anything I'm with you
um and B
um
I never
there's very few times I say never
almost never have I regretted being
generous
there's very few times I look back
unless I was guilted into it okay but
there's very few times I look back that
uh not counting business
I I you know because they're in there
working and I'm just trying I'm doing
well God's blessed me why not you know
why not just be easy with it don't be so
that God give them hard case but I do
resent this spin thing at the counter
and that is guilting I'm not doing that
I'm not doing the ten dollar thing I
skipped The Starving Children add on at
the thing I'll take care of starving
children through one of the Ministries
the Ramsey Foundation that you've added
that we support that we've added and
that we spend a whole lot more than ten
dollars I can promise you that and give
a whole lot more than ten dollars to
that so we're doing our part so to speak
but just not through
XYZ grocery store yeah and usually
there's a compliment as they spin it
it's hey uh you know I love your hair
you ever get one of those that though
that they never say that to me I never
get love your hair that's sad if they
tried that you'd get a really big tip
from Dave if you try that it never comes
up no I it wouldn't because that would
not be real it would be well there's an
expectation if Dave Ramsey wants a Smart
ankle you love my hair what do you oh
yeah what's wrong with you but do you
feel pressure as a public figure known
for money in general absolutely you know
absolutely not going to tell this story
and winning when in doubt if I'm going
to give them a Dave story it ought to be
a good one that's right so uh when in
doubt God's made giving me a lot of
money to manage and so I'm it's easy I
don't that I don't feel guilty about
um but I'm just very careful and
Sharon's like you way over tip and I'm
like yep yep and when I get to heaven no
one's going to go nope you're not
getting in here because you over tipped
you're an overtipper it didn't work St
Peter's Never Gonna know you can't come
in you over tip Davis bad use of money
because it to me it's a form of
generosity in the appropriate situations
this one gee this one's right down the
middle for me so what what I'm gonna I'm
trying to visualize walking in because I
don't do this very often yeah like if we
go to a get a bunch of barbecue like you
said a big order that's what I'm saying
like we got a family reunion coming up
Sharon will send me up to the barbecue
place and I'm picking up like boxes of
crap you know pickles like 80 gallons of
pickles you know I gotta go to these
parties all this stuff man it's all well
there's a big family and so when I'm
doing that somebody has worked their
tail off on that yeah I'm definitely
gonna Jack that one up so but if Dave's
passion I don't know a single person's
order that's generally my situation
personally do that so I don't know how I
would react I'm probably when in doubt
they'll be generous you never messes up
but is it a mandatory cultural thing no
so is it a generosity move if you do it
yes this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Colin
and Olivia are with us hey guys how are
you hi good how are you better than I
deserve welcome welcome where do you
live we live in Portland Michigan all
right what's that near
um Lansing ah okay gotcha cool welcome
to Nashville and how much data have you
guys paid off so we've paid off about 61
000 in total
um we got married in the process so
together paid off about 49 000. ah okay
of which 49 cents marriage yeah gotcha
okay and how long since you started
working on the 61 back
um 13 months in total okay very cool how
long y'all been married it's in
September oh wow all right very good
still fresh
and uh what's your uh what's your range
of incomes in the last 13 months um so I
started as an intern making about 49 and
then when we got married
um we I got into my career and we got
married and at about 1 30. yeah
excellent cool what I'll do for a living
so I'm a packaging engineer I'm a field
service tech for heavy equipment very
good good for you gosh what kind of debt
was just 61 000. so about 54
000 was student loans
um I had a car loan a furnace loan and a
credit card okay the way she says that
Colin you had nothing
actually had nothing yeah no doubt at
all I was the baggage no debt at all
okay all right so when you got married
you kind of stepped into this journey
she was already on yeah yeah I I
actually got home one day and I walked
in and the credit cards were cut up on
the on the kitchen table I was like okay
well we're doing this it just got real
were you shocked by all this as she
started the debt free Journey uh no I uh
went to high school and we kind of had a
financial peace class so I always I knew
about it and I was all for it from the
beginning yeah so what got you fired up
and on track Olivia um
right before I graduated college and um
what's your degree in um
science oh okay of course so
um was on my internship and I got a call
from the bank and I had 300 a month in
interest payments and they call just
saying that they needed more money and I
was like I don't have more money so and
I was not sure what to do and I started
crying at my desk and my co-worker Chris
was like have you heard of Dave Ramsey
and I was like I never have and
um I didn't learn about this in school
so he turned me onto the podcast and it
was just like that same day I mean all
day every day while I was working when I
was you know going on a walk it was just
a total mindset shift from then so wow
he really turned me on to it very cool
very cool well congratulations thank you
so nothing like a little a little stress
to make you search out a wake-up call oh
yeah let's go yeah definitely yeah there
was definitely
um a point where I would not go check my
mail and I was like I just can't I can't
live like this anymore I needed to go
get my mail but I was afraid of the
bills and I was afraid of the payments
and I would just never I didn't even
know how much debt I had until I started
listening to the show because I was
afraid to check so yeah you don't want
to add it up exactly
yeah to all of you out there who uh see
a co-worker crying at their desk and
recommend Dave Ramsey thank you yes we
appreciate it that is one of our more uh
popular marketing techniques actually
yeah well it's a risky one because you
know a lot of the times people don't
listen what caused you to go I'm open to
are you just at that kind of rock bottom
moment where you went I'll try anything
yeah definitely I think that it was like
um one of my my co-worker had said if
what you're doing isn't working then you
obviously need to change what you're
doing and I was like well it's not
working so why not um yeah exactly I had
nothing to lose at that point even if it
didn't work I was like well I mean I I
tried and
um luckily it did the first thing I
tried I wasn't into you know um I wasn't
really big into the financial game so
um this is the first thing I tried and
it was the only thing I'll probably ever
do I think so good well it's all you'll
need to do if you keep doing it I
promise you Wow way to go so how does it
feel to be completely free just a few
months into your all's marriage feels so
good yeah we're
house on Friday yeah
I love it well congratulations thank you
that's a long way to go from not being
able to pay your 300 Bill yes yes very
cool congratulations good stuff all
right what do you two tell people uh
young married couple out there that's
thinking I don't know if I can do this
or not what do you tell them the key to
getting out of debt is I would say just
be consistent there's always a light at
the end of the tunnel even if it's super
dim don't listen to the people around
you because they're all dumb and they
don't know what they're doing
um I'd say just just except for that one
guy exactly when you were crying yeah
just sticking with it and just like if
you know what you're doing is not
working
um you need a solution and you need a
way out so I mean just find it within
yourself to be mad at yourself for doing
that so yeah and I think the big thing
for like I mean me at least was I'm
pretty Visionary learner I guess so we
had like a chart on the fridge and we'd
color it as we paid off debt and yeah
watching that debt go down was kind of a
dead thermometer thing yeah that's a big
deal man you got to have that I think
we're all that way uh to some more so
than others but but everybody it never
hurts to have it right in front of you
and go hey I'm winning hey this
sacrifice is paying off right hey we're
you know it's like looking down the
scale you lost some weight if you're
trying to lose weight you know yeah I
think I can drink a little more water
this is working you know so all whatever
it is you're doing you keep doing it
because we're moving the needle finally
in the right direction yeah very good
good stuff wow you guys are impressive
there's so many couples out there that
go yeah we have the debt but we really
want the house right so they just do
everything all at once and then they
wake up one day and they go this ain't
it and you guys did it slow and steady
what would you tell those couples who
feel like they they want the house home
ownership is such a dream and you guys
waited and you did it the right way I
would probably just say one step at a
time like do get a goal finish the goal
before you move on I mean I always I
think the focus is just all my all of
our friends and family were like this is
crazy but I'm like the one step at a
time and the focus one thing after
another is just it makes so much of a
difference you know because B had been
looking at houses when we were
um in the process of paying off debt and
it just I was like I just can't do it
you know I didn't feel right until it
was gone you know yeah
well it's you know and now that the ones
that were uh you know they were kind of
saying you're crazy now look at you I've
only been married since September and
You're Dead free and got a house yes
ding ding so how you like me now you
know right I like it so well done you
guys proud of you excellent work hey
we've got uh the live and give box for
you it includes a baby steps
millionaires book latest number one
bestseller that's the track your own to
be millionaires and The Total Money
Makeover book which is the process you
followed to get out of debt and a
Financial Peace University membership if
you've not been through the whole class
as a young married couple go through it
now even though you're out of debt it's
not only about getting out of debt it's
about handling money all the way to
wealth all the way to generosity so take
it if you're not taking it yet and I
will give it to you all as our gift for
coming to Nashville to do your debt free
scream awesome proud of you guys well
done Colin and Olivia from the Lansing
Michigan area 61 thousand paid off in 13
months
making 49 to 130 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
we're just free yeah
[Applause]
that's it
wow you know it is a a combination of
what the 12-steppers say she said the
line twice if you don't like the results
you're getting you know continuing to do
the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result is the
definition of insanity that's the 12
steppers right and if you don't like the
results you're getting it's time to
change the recipe if you're baking a
cake and it keeps turning out chocolate
and you wanted vanilla change the recipe
something's wrong right you're not
getting what you want out of this thing
you can't keep doing the same thing so
she made a change
that is such a basic human thing and yet
so many people just continue to do the
same thing go well I don't know you
think that we're elected a new president
maybe I'll be okay no doofus it's you
you gotta change you me I'm looking in
the mirror I go you you guy in the
mirror doofus you gotta change you
you're the problem and that's exactly
what Olivia did man she changed
everything yeah I mean it's one of the
greatest gifts God has given man is free
will to stop doing stupid stuff and do
smarter stuff that sounds like a
theologian right there I don't know if
that made it into the Bible free will to
stop doing stupid stuff that's my spark
notes and second hesitations there we go
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Solutions Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
paying off debt is smart that enables
you to save and invest which is smart
enables you to be generous which is
smart but also you not only play offense
you need to play defense and that's good
insurance
protecting your finances from
emergencies there's ten kinds of
insurance that you might need and a
whole bunch of Kinds you don't need
and we built a tool to help you figure
this out it's completely free it's
called the coverage checkup tool tells
you which types to add which types to
drop which types to adjust even ranks
your coverage list by importance we'll
email it back to you from our Ramsay
trusted insurance providers you can get
the plan in place fast and uh it'll be
might be the five most important five
minutes of free you do this year could
end up saving you a ton of money because
sometimes we're buying the wrong kinds
of insurance or buying Insurance the
wrong ways so visit ramseysolutions.com
checkup
ramsesolutions.com
checkup Alvin Is With Us in North Dakota
hey Alvin welcome to the Ramsay show
good afternoon gentlemen it's a pleasure
to speak with you sure what's up
well my question is should I pause baby
step two to stack up cash for my son's
private school or should I cash flow it
monthly when he starts to attend
how much is it
it's 6 000 yearly
six thousand dollars a year
yes sir and what do you make what's your
household income
um 91 000 a year okay
all right
um
is it all due is it is it normally paid
they have a monthly plan is that what
you're saying
yes sir do they charge an interest or an
extra fee on the monthly plan
it's a fifty dollar fee to pay monthly
one time or each month
one time
okay
um
hmm
I probably would just make it a monthly
just put it in my budget what do you
think George well I think putting you
know 500 bucks as a line item in your
budget and still allowing you to make
Headway on your debt I like that plan
better than just waiting until you know
we have the money because what's running
through my head is either way you're
going to have to put his line item in
your budget
you're gonna have a sinking fun now I'm
building up a pile of cash here and I'm
throwing 500 bucks a month at that for
10 months
or for 12 months so I've got six
thousand dollars
um or I'm you know whatever 600 for 10
or however you want to break it down
1500 for four I don't whatever it is
some way or another I'm going to end up
having a line item in my budget and I
think I'll just make it a monthly
payment what is left on your debt
I have 15 000 left on my bed okay all
right and you can do this it's not an
outrageous percentage of your the uh of
your household income
uh which might lead me to an objection
for private schools whether or not you
can afford it but I think you can afford
this and still get out of the other
stuff don't you
yes sir I think they can yeah yeah I
think you just I what are you leaning
towards Alvin which way would you rather
do it there's not a wrong answer okay as
long as you're paying for it you're not
putting it on a credit card we're fine
so which way would you rather do it
would you rather do it monthly or uh
just back it up and do it
um I was leaning toward
packing it up and paying it at once okay
but then I then I also fear that
if I have all that money set aside
um
and an emergency happens I'll be looking
at that as well I need to use that now
yeah well I mean if you can't uh you
know pinky swearing spit Shake You're
Gonna Keep your money's hands off of it
then if you if you're not comfortable
you're gonna keep your hands off it then
I wouldn't I would not stack it but um
what kind of debt is the 15
it's a auto loan it's my my only debt
yeah how quick you're gonna have that
clear
um without the private schooling I would
be done in 10 months
okay so you're not necessarily doing the
private schooling
uh I am doing it he's enrolled but okay
so so I don't think without the private
schooling is not an option then
no so without it it's 10 months you're
saying it'll take an extra what six
months beyond that
yes okay I would also find a way to make
it up and go how can I make an extra six
grand over the next 12 months said I
don't hold back the debt payoff process
yeah let's
um let's Jack this up tighten down the
budget and raise the income if possible
to add some fuel to the fire if you
aren't comfortable that you're going to
leave the money alone if something pops
up then I would not stack it uh you know
just one of the things I have to do is I
have to put systems in place to guard me
from me
and I do that quite frequently like
there are no Donuts in my house
because if they're there I will eat them
and so I just don't have Donuts in my
house that's a Temptation that's a
system I have no Donuts in my house and
my wife does not bring donuts into my
house well Sharon wouldn't touch a donut
uh no she's Health Food nut but he but
she knows I'll eat them it would be
vegan and gluten-free Dave's that's not
even a real real food it's not real
Donuts but yeah so I mean you have to
build systems in to keep you
uh automatic like I I put a bunch of our
investing stuff on automatic draft and
then I've not thought about it in 15
years it just automatically comes out
every month I've got a big chunk that
comes out of my uh personal account and
goes into a s p 500 for investing in
real estate later it's a big old check
every month and it's been coming out
there forever and I'm just not used to
it not being forget about it it's like
it's not there you know it's Auto so it
was a book many years ago that was a
bestseller David Bach wrote called
automatic millionaire yes and his
concept was put as many things on
autopilot as you can and I I don't
disagree with that it's easier than
trying to trying to form a habit oh that
our friend James Clear would talk about
from Atomic habits but but two good
books both worth reading but the uh uh
yeah that's that's the way to look at it
so Alvin I try to protect me from me and
you've you said that about you so I'm
putting yours on payments that's the
first step of self-awareness that's what
I'm doing I'm just gonna pay the extra
50 bucks and let it run I did that with
uh early in our budgeting career
I uh put the budget billing on the
utilities
same amount every month and then once a
year there's a true up you're either
over or you're short and there's a true
up once a year and it's not dramatic
because they're estimating estimating
system is pretty was pretty good back in
those days we don't do that now so but
uh that helped me smooth the budget out
so I always knew what utilities are
going to be except once a year
and uh and you pay a little extra fee
for that and I actually have my car
insurance back in the day because when I
first started doing this stuff I had
quarterly car insurance talk about a
nightmare wow once a quarter yeah save
save save pay save save save pay so it
was just a mini sinking funds it's like
it was all the time it was always paying
it's felt like so I just put the thing I
paid an extra I don't know like he said
30 bucks a year or something just put it
on a monthly and never thought about it
again until I finally wasn't using that
company and I just went to an annual
many years later now it's easier because
I use every dollar and they have sinking
funds you can set up in there so once a
year I pay my annual insurance premiums
you have to what happened the trick of
that is you have to emotionally divorce
yourself from the money yes like it's
gone
I came out and it's over there in the
education kids private school fund and I
don't own that money anymore it's like
it's gone emotionally it's like that
money coming out for an investment it's
not there I can't buy a I can't buy a
toy with it because it's not for toys
it's for Investments it's gone
and you kind of if you get you you have
to get
some maturity well that that's just in
discipline I've done it for 30 years so
it's easy but the uh I had to
set it aside I had to have a separate
account savings account just for the
emergency fund never touch that one
account that's the account that has a do
not touch stamp on it and I've never
touched it
oddly enough I've never had an emergency
big enough in in decades so you could
even get close to it that I couldn't
cash flow yeah and some of that is I've
got a pretty good cash position but uh
but but it just it's not there that
money is not even in my it's not even in
my emotional equation and that's just
really important folks that you you set
yourself up for winning like that those
are good good thoughts from um and
really in a sense that's what uh
clear talks about in atomic habits as
well so good stuff George Campbell or MC
personality I'm Dave Ramsey your host
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books
[Music]
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsey show but we help people
build wealth to work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
this is a baby steps millionaires theme
hour we're going to talk to real
millionaires people who have a net worth
of a million dollars or greater and we
want to find out the real story of how
they did that we don't want your broke
brother-in-law's opinion he always has
one and he votes wrong so we need to
check out what's going on here where do
millionaires really come from George
Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today to clarify if you're a
caller on this show this hour you have a
net worth of a million dollars or
greater that is the definition it is an
accounting metric of a millionaire a net
worth is a math calculation it is not a
feeling it is not a moral construct it
is not a spiritual state it is a math
formula the math formula is this what
you own minus what you owe is your net
worth your assets minus your liabilities
is your net worth so for instance if the
only thing you own was a mortgage was a
home and you owe it's worth two hundred
thousand dollars and you had a fifty
thousand dollar mortgage your net worth
would be one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
that's your net worth what you own minus
what you are thanks for the
clarification Dave I've had to get in
some fights in the YouTube comments
because of idiots who go well unless you
have a million liquid cash you're not a
millionaire it's a cash millionaire
that's different
but your house doesn't count because you
can't your house access to how that it's
it's a balance sheet it's what you would
know if you actually took an accounting
class
so idiots in Tic Tac didn't have
accounting classes and so they're out
there running around running their mouth
about what a real millionaire is a
million I actually heard a U.S
congressman say the other day all of
these millionaires that make a million
dollars a year
no ma'am you're stupid
and so are the people that elected you
oh my god a million dollar income does
not make you a millionaire it could lead
you to having a million dollars you can
make a million dollars and be broke
turns out you could spend 2 million oh
wait that's in Congress yeah that's
where they learned it yeah okay so the
deal is
a million dollar net worth and we're
going to talk about the mythology around
wealth in America today where it really
comes from where it doesn't but we're
going to talk to real millionaires
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll start with Canada making sure
they got some millionaires north of the
Border Kyle is with us hey Kyle what's
your net worth
hey Dave and George it's a pleasure to
talk to you guys you too I'm uh we're
just just over 1 million between 1 and
1.1 that counts brother give me a little
breakdown on the mix of that how is that
distributed among what kind of assets
well I'll tell you what I mean it's it's
only a Canadian million so I'm not
technically as wealthy as your other
American millionaires but it counts for
me you're close a Canadian millionaire
we're giving a whole new look all right
perfect okay so uh I've got about half a
million in my business that's that's
equipment uh mostly uh 165 000 in a tfsa
between myself and my wife
115k in rrsps incredible 75k in a high
interest savings account a hundred
thousand in cash uh and about a hundred
150 in home equity way to go good job
how old are you
we are
29.99
all right so how much of this did you
inherit
uh financially I have yet to inherit
anything
um what I did in here at Dave I've got
two super supportive parents that uh
that taught me how to handle Money young
and supported me getting started so
exactly nothing so far I taught you how
to work
taught me how to work and taught me how
to save yeah yeah so what is your uh
where in your working lifetime what was
your best Year's income and your worst
years income so far
we recorded about 250 net profit and I
mean
net net profit yeah okay good and uh and
when I first started I mean I first
started at the lumber yard at 16 as soon
as I had a driver's license for 10 bucks
an hour working four hour shifts in the
evenings so not very much okay cool so
what is your career you said heavy
equipment
uh yes yeah I uh I'm in uh heavy
equipment in the agricultural space I do
custom farming for guys actually brow
cleaning is my main main gig very cool
very cool you got a four-year degree
two-year degree any degree
yeah from uh technology Institute okay
what was your GPA
a little less than three I don't
remember exactly but it's like 2.7 2.8
something like that gotcha okay and so
uh can it be done now can you be a
millionaire today if you start from
nothing you're 29 you did it quick
absolutely yeah I I have no doubt that
anybody can do it if they want to spend
their time and invest to do it for sure
what do you think the secret to yours
was
I mean when I started working Dave I
just saved 80 90 of my income and and
waited for opportunities to come along
and when an opportunity came along to
get into a business
I was able to buy in with cash and and
grow it from there and I've operated in
the block ever since I love it so you
avoid debt completely
I do yeah uh besides our mortgage on our
house we're only about three three
Thirty on our house something like that
um but other than that I I do have to be
honest I've got a credit card just
because uh I use it for the things where
it's more convenient you know to book a
hotel room or or pay for gas or whatever
but I'm very very picky about what I put
on there well congratulations Kyle we
appreciate you hanging out with us
you're a true first generation
millionaire very very well done so for
those of you that are new to this
process baby steps millionaires is the
number one best-selling book uh it came
out a year ago January that I did and
the back of it is the white paper from
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in North America 10
167 of them we studied George and our
Ramsey research team is uh they're some
of the best researchers in this type of
space anywhere in America oh yeah and we
used a third-party research panel as
well to make this thing Ironclad so that
it didn't wasn't too close to home and
so all of that together I mean this I
haven't seen a study this big in a long
time when it comes to personal finances
yeah it was massive because we didn't
want anyone to argue with the sample
size we only had a thousand people Dave
yeah so thousands technically in a
situation like this statistically
significant but like accounting not
everybody's had the class right so they
don't know that what statistical
significance actually means it is
actually a math formula once again so
um anyway the uh the process was that we
put these guys together studied all of
these millionaires
ones that knew about Ramsey ones that
didn't know about Ramsey ones that have
been through our stuff ones that had
never heard of me in their life and got
some very very clear indications where
millionaires come from in North America
we'll share some of those with you as we
go through the hour baby steps
billionaires theme hour here on the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
it's a baby steps
millionaires theme hour order
millionaires really come from
well you have to be able to play
professional sports
be a rock star a country star or an
actor
less than one percent point eight
percent of America's millionaires
are names you recognize
just doesn't come from those places
and so if you're growing up in a
situation where you think the only way
out of your situation is professional
sports
you are statistically
exactly wrong
it's the least likely way out
percentage-wise
the number of football players in high
school or basketball players in high
school that go on to play division one
is a is very very small the number of
division one athletes that go on to be
professionals is even smaller
it is a fraction of a percentile you're
not going to win that way the way you're
going to win is controlling your
spending and working on your income
and this is how people build wealth
realistically with a high probability in
America today hi Greg is in Cincinnati
Greg your net worth sir a 1.2 million
dollars Dave thanks for having me on
certainly give me a little breakdown on
that by category yeah so right now we've
got about 500 000 in the house we've got
about four hundred thousand in
retirement accounts and then the balance
is spread up between kids college mutual
fund cash
gotcha cool how old are you
from 41 uh my wife says 40. awesome how
much of this did you inherit
well so no no lump sum you know great
grandfather did a cool thing I did an
annuity type thing so we got we did get
an extra 15
000 a year for the last 13 years which
was kind of cool so not a huge amount
but I mean it it actually helps when we
weren't making a lot of money definitely
definitely helps that's a lot of money
when you're not making a lot of money uh
but if you just mathematically piled it
up for 10 years it's 150 Grand right
yeah exactly cool so what's been your
income your best year in work share of
your working life
sure um
best year was last year we made over 420
000 which was an anomaly
um I'm in software sales now and so
obviously had a good year but for the 14
years of where we were really sticking
to the plan the detail plan the first
seven years we were household income of
ninety thousand and then the last seven
years before last year was a hundred and
seventy one thousand so I moved from
marketing into Tech sales and that
obviously helped the bump up in average
yeah so you're in Tech sales today all
right what's your degree in
uh marketing and Logistics okay what was
your GPA
Dave don't worry about it no I'm just
kidding uh
three but my wife is not to be
discounted here she was a teacher she
her income obviously helped a ton right
and she has two degrees in undergrad and
um a masters of education okay actually
she was 4.0 she would want me to tell
you that all right yeah well we know who
the smarter one is okay all right
exactly yeah you married her uh yeah all
right good so uh are you guys book
people or TV people do you read in the
evenings or watch TV
um we try to be booked people but it's
probably about 50 50. okay I'm being
honest that's good we're probably 75-25
Sharon hears about some kind of crap on
Netflix we turn on every so often but
most the time it's a book okay cool I
like that and then Dave's hooked on The
Bachelor from then on yeah and then I
have to lose my man card and watch
Downton Abbey or whatever it is yeah so
that's it but yeah
that was a while back so this was an old
joke it's like a 14-year Journey for you
how long did this take kind of when you
were getting intentional about it to go
like we want to hit this milestone
yeah good question the the first uh
about four years we were really
intentional got turned on to Dave
through the radio show and then the
books and realized how dumb I really was
um so we got out of debt within the
first few years a lot of Life happened
babies fertility paying off tuition
paying off credit cards so the last half
of the journey has been a little bit
slower as we've completed the baby steps
and then you know last year enabled us
to actually pay off the house as of
awesome they were now completely uh yeah
baby step seven and that dropped you
into the million dollar category yeah
perfect as it should be well done Greg
proud of you man good work Donna is in
Huntsville Donna what's your net worth
uh probably in the neighborhood of 9
million I love it give me a little
breakdown on that
105 000 IRAs
um
one and a half million and a regular
brokerage account and about
seventy thousand thereabouts in regular
bank account
okay
um
three million dollars in mortgage notes
and probably four million dollars in
real estate ah real estate people all
right person love it real estate person
yeah all right how old are you I'm 66.
all right cool so how much of this did
you inherit well actually a few years
ago I mean what way past the time that I
needed it I inherited a hundred thousand
dollars from a friend of mine when he
died so you were already a millionaire
oh yeah easy yeah easy okay so you're
not a millionaire because of inherited
money all right and what has been your
income best year working in your
lifetime and we're sure
six years old my worst year I made about
five thousand dollars a year okay
you know garbage jobs
um looked around listened to the 55 year
old women complaining about the same
thing I was complaining about not being
able to pay their rent hardly and said I
was gonna have to make some changes or
in another 30 years or so that would be
me good call um so I went to school and
got an engineering degree
um I I had a bachelor's in philosophy
already uh quick story on that is I was
a semester short of getting an
accounting degree and had the Epiphany I
was thinking thank God this is almost
over and then realized what kind of job
do you think you get with an accounting
degree
and decide that wasn't for me so changed
my major at the last minute and got out
um
but I also have master's degrees in
physics Applied Mathematics and
electrical engineering wow so what has
been your career these last few decades
any of that I I work as an engineer for
a couple of years and uh you just like
collecting degrees for fun like trophies
exactly
but clearly you're good at real estate
what did you do for a career
well
when I got divorced I got stuck with a
couple of rental properties and I kind
of like that and uh I didn't have that
much money so I bought a condemned house
and had no construction background but
figured I'd figure it out and I did
and I got to wear them quite good at it
I do the massive remodels I bet so you
started your worst year was a five
thousand dollar income and what has been
your top year earning okay now it's a
little hard to say
currently I should be knocking back
about 700 000 a year now part of that is
you know return of investment on real
mortgages sure and then I've got some
expenses with the uh so did you sell
those property and hold back the notes
or did you buy notes discounted
and I hold the paper out okay and I
actually I went to the Chiefs so I'm
actually making more money off mortgages
more income from a mortgage than I am
from the rent
well yeah you're sitting on a bunch of
it yeah okay yep yes I'm sitting on a
bunch of it Well Done Donna you're
amazing
so I was going to ask you if you've got
a degree but you've got seven so you
might need a list and your GPA must be
4.2 on these things oh heck no heck no
uh you know I was doing your stuff
before you were doing your stuff you're
right yeah that's probably true I mean
I'm serious I always had a thousand
dollars and it's amazing that thousand
dollars really does stop you from having
it crises yeah when you're right on the
edge it keeps you off the edge you're
right Good Stuff Donna well done wow
nine million dollars that's pretty
amazing
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today this hour we're doing a
baby steps millionaires theme hour
four myths four lies
that people say and some people believe
about wealthy people
number one they're brilliant
they have an inordinate amount of brain
power
in other words their gpas are all 4.2
not true
not true we already heard that this hour
2.7 in there yeah we got a uh two under
three and one 4.0 uh the typical
millionaire the typical person we talked
to that is wealthy
has around a 3.0 GPA
if they remember it
[Laughter]
is that like just straight average is
that kind of a beat right at the you
know three 3.2 something like that right
in there is what we find uh we didn't
actually study that in the Ramsey
millionaire study that's just from us
hanging out with millionaires for many
years now uh I find over and over and
over again you really can't be dumb
I mean like I have a 1.0 GPA like you
played beer pong the whole time or
something you can't be dumb and
typically build wealth you generally
have to have some level of intellect
some ability critical thinking skills
ability to stick with something ability
to think through something but um but it
does not require that you're a genius
which means I have a chance so you're
saying there's a chance right Dumb and
Dumber quotes so there you go but um
yeah I'm saying there's a chance I'm
saying there's a chance um there is
very uh sadly they're they're while
they're while intellect a level of
intellect is there the other thing we
find is not a necessary level of
education completed uh although we find
a large number have college degrees uh
but the um what we do find is they're
almost all lifetime Learners like our
last one Donna 66 years old with nine
million dollars she continued to go back
and get degrees because she started in a
dead-end job making nothing looking
around at 55 year old broke women going
I'm going to be one of them I don't want
to be one of them so what does she do
she just kept learning and even when she
got a divorce what'd she do she went and
bought a condemned house I don't know
how to fix it up but I think I can
figure it out figure it out continual
learner continual learner continue a
learner always reading always growing
always learning always putting something
new in their cap how many books have you
read since the first of the year I've
completed three non-fiction books this
month I'm on a roll I'm on a roll I
don't usually do that many a month but
I'm on a roll right now and I've got uh
I've got a great non-fiction Jack Carr's
new ones laying on there a great a
fiction book I'm sorry it's a great one
and then I've got a non-fiction laying
on my desk right now that I'm getting
ready to start too and I'm just going to
tear into them just I find everything I
want in a book reading reading reading
reading reading reading so I see that a
lot with millionaires they you know yes
I admit it I watched Tiger King but I
also read okay and so I have to offset
my brain the real admissions that I
killed watching Tiger King have to be
replenished by reading so that's it so
yeah I mean we all do we all do some
things we regret it was 20 20. it was a
tough year for us it was a hard year it
was a very hard year for for a lot of
tigers and so um my favorite stat in
there was that 97 of the millionaires
believe they control their Destiny I
want that is profound because most 69 of
the public does yeah so comparatively to
the general public there's a high
correlation of I believe I can do it
yeah if you think you can you think you
can't you're right and here's one of the
ones that I think is so classic it fits
with this uh envy and jealousy culture
that we're building which is kind of a a
core tenet of socialism right you know I
have to Envy someone I have to hate
someone's success I have to be jealous
of someone's success and this one Falls
in that bucket all wealthy people are
Crooks because that's known way to
become wealthy you have to be crooked
and the weird thing is I've met 10 I've
met thousands and thousands of
millionaires 30 years doing this and I
have met hmm
over 50 in person had conversations with
them billionaires and that's a thousand
million and out of those billionaires I
only know
two of them
that I can remember that are complete
butts
they were complete and if I named them
you would know them I mean they're that
they're that kind of butt
and they're like famous butts you know
that's one of the best kind yeah and so
uh but the the rest of them are some of
the nicest people on the planet because
here here's this is fat this is a truth
broken logic okay the logic of this says
you rip people off to get money
the problem with that is
that when you rip someone off
word gets around
and the next one is harder to rip off
and then word gets around and the next
one's even harder to rip off so you're
running a business let's just call it a
car repair place and you
don't repair someone's car and you
overcharge them you rip them off
so if that's you and you get ripped off
by the car repair guy what do you do
you tell your friends stay away from put
it on Facebook yeah don't go stay away
from this guy he's a crook right leave a
bad review yeah and and pretty soon the
guy's out of business he's not wealthy
but if the guy takes really good care of
you going he goes hey that he spends
about five minutes fixing your car and
goes oh it's just one little thing here
he turns a screw and what I owe you
buddy nothing just remember me when you
have a real car repair and tell your
friends
well guess what you do you remember when
you have a real car repair and you tell
your friends and you look up 10 years
later and the guys got shops in five
cities
and he's worth about 10 million dollars
because all he did was honestly repair
someone's car a lot
that's all he did
and he's got a net worth of five or ten
million dollars they're all over the
place so it turns out the best way to
become wealthy's high integrity is what
the actual critical thinking leads us to
believe versus ripping people off so
this idea that all the rich people are
Crooks all that means is you're a
small-minded jealous person who doesn't
know how life works that doesn't say
anything about rich people it may say
something about you well maybe the logic
doesn't make sense because if they get
wealthy that automatically makes them a
crook based on their own logic well that
means you wouldn't want to get wealthy
that's the person that's saying that I
wouldn't want to be rich because all
those rich people are bad people and
it's quite the opposite most of them are
really good people who've helped a lot
of people that's how they become wealthy
you know and I've noticed this about us
no one was pissed off when I sold ten
dollar books helping people get out of
debt out of the trunk of my car and I
helped 10 people and I sold 10 books
making ten dollars nobody was mad but
now that I've sold 20 million of them
Dave Ramsey got rich on the backs of
poor people
no I helped more people than I did when
I was doing another trunk of my car a
lot more people got help now and they
gave you certificates because of scale
I'm automatically Evil all that means is
you're an idiot if you say stuff like
that that's all that means and that's
not me being defensive it's just your
critical thinking skills suck when you
do that I mean you're just exposing
yourself it's just bad so
millionaires come from hard work and
honesty
who knew Andrew is in Irvine
California Andrew what's your net worth
very cool getting on which website you
believe when it comes to the house value
Ah that's cool and so give me a little
breakdown on the 1.3 million
all right so I have 385 in traditional
IRAs 180 in Roth IRAs 30 in a taxable
mutual fund 10 in individual stocks nine
in an HSA account 90 in cash and
somewhere between 600 and 900 in the
house uh Zillow says it's worth 900 I
don't believe them okay but it's
probably worth eight yeah well done man
how old are you
34. 4 34. wow how much of this did you
inherit
uh not a penny my parents are still
alive my grandparents are still alive
okay very good and how much of this did
you steal
not a penny I don't believe in that
referencing the last rant okay yeah very
good all right and what's your best year
of working income in your worst year
uh worst year would be right after I
graduated college I was making 14 an
hour and best year was 2017 my wife and
I grossed about 350. what's your what's
your degree in
foreign
school is easy
well you're really good at it clearly
obviously very good congratulations
Andrew thanks for sharing your story
this is baby steps millionaire theme
hour here on the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today First Corinthians 9
27 but I discipline my body and keep it
under control lest after preaching to
others I myself should be disqualified
Clint Eastwood said self-respect leads
to self-discipline when you have both
firmly under your belt that is real
power from the one and only there you go
hey guys if you've changed your life
with the money principles we teach
chances are someone you know helped you
they let a fire under you they guided
you Mom and Dad gave you tmmo as a gift
your pastor offered Financial Peace
University at your church
well now it's your chance to share that
same kind of hope
and a good way to do it is by living by
giving them the live and give box
it's the perfect gift for a newlywed or
a graduate in your life it's everything
you need to win it comes with Financial
Peace University the best thing we do in
the building
The Total Money Makeover book and baby
steps Millionaires and right now you get
all of this for just 89 but just for a
few more days so talk about a gift that
matters it's called hope Freedom grab
this live and give box today only 89
bucks at
ramseysolutions.com slash box Lisa and
Alan are in Sacramento hey guys what's
your net worth
at that point we found you and started
slowly climbing back out we did our debt
free scream 20 months later in 2010
and you told us we would be millionaires
again and I thought you were crazy
but guess what we followed the baby
steps and our current net worth is 1.2
million
I bet it's a lot more solid this time
you bet it is yeah how old are you guys
64. so you're like me you had to do it
twice yeah
I like this one all right so give me a
little breakdown on the 1.2 million
how's it broken down by category
1 million and 25
000. in retirement we have about 370
000 and cash 150
000. okay I'm getting more than 1.2 then
oh well we have a mortgage oh you do
okay all right and on the morning so
that reduces the net okay I got you okay
cool very cool all right and so how much
of this did you inherit
zero okay cool and uh so what are your
careers
I'm an arc
my own
Okay cool so obviously you have an
architectural degree and
um what was your GPA in that 3.5 okay
very good all right so you guys are the
comeback story
what uh advice would you give to the 25
year old version of you listening so
they only do it once
I would say beware of real estate
investment schemes that turn out to be
scams
oh I remember you guys oh yeah
yeah oh whoa those were some numbers
yeah yeah
wow it was not just a like not not a bad
advice this is a true actual actual scam
right it was
the CEO of the company has been in
prison for quite a while wow wow
wow and you guys climbed out how would
you advise someone this is so
interesting how would you advise someone
avoid that
oh how do you keep from getting scammed
if
there you go I like that one
did you have a sense at any point
like something early in the process like
something doesn't feel right but you
went ahead anyway
when we
took out a mortgage on our property is
getting close to being free and clear
to invest in this didn't feel right damn
yeah so anytime someone says hey give me
this money I'll turn it into 10x that
yeah yeah one of those yeah
oh man wow I'm proud of you guys for
climbing out of that you guys are
impressive negative four million feels
unsurmountable oh yeah all the way to
back positive 1.2 that's very cool I
told you it would be and you know how I
knew you would be is once you've been in
this once you've have breathed that air
you know what it smells like
and you know it can be done it's like
one time I wrote a bicycle and then I
had a wreck but I knew I could ride a
bicycle still because I had done it
before it wasn't Theory anymore
and so they always say the second
million is easier it is because you know
you can do it I've done it once I can do
it again I just won't do it as stupid
this time I'll I'll be smarter you know
and and that's how I felt anyway and so
I I'm convinced that that's that the
second million if you have to do it
twice is always easier way to go you
guys I'm so happy to hear from you and
ding ding ding I'm happy I was right
that you're back wow I like being right
about a lot of things but I really like
being right and you always wonder where
are they now and we just found out yeah
that that was a few but that was a true
I mean millions and millions of dollars
lost a real scam so
um the last lie changing the subject
about millionaires that is told is
they all inherit their money
factually
not true no trust funds involved today
that no some do inherit money
they all hit the lotto factually not
true now by facts I mean actual data not
Theory
not my opinion not your opinion not a
feeling you had
not your Marxist teacher from college
but the real world is of the largest
study airtight research the research
technique is so squeaky clean no
confirmation bias had double double
looks on it our team was running one set
of programs the outside team is running
another set of programs to make sure we
weren't accidentally stumbling into
conclusions that we thought very good
research and so to the point that if you
don't agree with the net discoveries of
This research on this solid data you're
what's known as wrong
that's scientific there we go it's that
solid so 79 of the millionaires that we
talk to inherited precisely zero
another five percent did get an
inheritance but it was like five
thousand dollars from Grandmother
and it was not enough mathematically to
make you a millionaire and another five
percent
got a substantial inheritance like Donna
did earlier in the hour 66 years old
received a hundred thousand dollar
inheritance
after they were already millionaires
so it's hard to say that the inheritance
caused her to be a millionaire because
it came after she was already a
millionaire so 79 nothing five a little
bit five after already 79 5 and 5 is 89.
okay that's nine out of ten of America's
millionaires are first generation Rich
so don't let the Hope Stealers the crazy
leftists tell you that America is so
broken that you can't get ahead today
there's always been challenges there's
always been problems there will always
be isms there will always be idiots in
your way count on it
but you can do it
don't let people tell you can't do it
and that's the whole theme of this hour
and for that matter of everything we do
at Ramsey you can do it and I love how
boring this is I mean you heard the
mixes of these numbers it's mostly
people's primary homes and their
retirement accounts and then some cash
position there was no flash but I didn't
hear any like crypto no one hit the
right single stock there wasn't the rice
and bright investment opportunity except
for a scam and so that gives me hope
that anyone can do this invest 15 of
your income into retirement pay off your
house early it's that simple and it's
that boring and that's that hopeful and
that gets you the first one to five
billion maybe even 10 million Donna got
to nine but Donna's got some real estate
in there and uh but there was nothing
fancy in any of this no uh double
backflip Family Trust Partnerships
which by the way don't exist but the
secrets of the rich are that they're
boring
that's the secret the secret is believe
the boring advice
uh good show guys as well done Austin
Finn James Zach Andrew Bob everybody in
the booth the booth dudes we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]